bonjour a tous eu aujourd'hui on va pas
de l'amour et on va
point de vue d'un philosophe qui s'est
penché sur la question
savoir jean-paul sartre
sartre est un philosophe et écrivain
français du xxème siècle
il est connu comme le fondateur de
l'existentialisme plus précisément de
l'existentialisme athée
un courant philosophique qui place au
premier plan la notion de liberté l'idée
que l'être humain se définit par sa
liberté
je vous renvoie sur ce sujet à mon
épisode sur sartre et l'existentialisme
et donc si on veut comprendre la
conception de l'amour que développe jean
paul sartre il va falloir garder à
l'esprit que cette question la liberté
elle est absolument centrale dans sa
réflexion sur l'amour
en effet pour sartre poser la question
de l'amour s'est posé la question du
rapport que nous entretenons avec la
liberté de l'autre
c'est poser la question de ce que nous
exigeons de l'être aimé
et de ce que nous faisons de lui lorsque
nous l'aimons
alors on va examiner tout ça dans le
détail mais avant ça je vais commencer
par évoquer quelques éléments personnels
de la vie de sartre de sa vie amoureuse
en l'occurrence non pas par voyeurisme
comparé indiscrétions mais tout
simplement parce que sartre a mis en
application dans sa vie personnelle les
conclusions philosophique de sa
réflexion sur l'amour
autrement dit il y à une correspondance
entre la conception philosophique que
sartre avait de l'amour et la manière
dont il a mené ses propres relations
amoureuses
et cette correspondance va constituer le
point de départ de notre réflexion
donc comme vous le savez sartre était en
couple avec simone de beauvoir
plus exactement ils étaient en relation
libre
alors on parle parfois de polyamour
voire de poly fidélité pour qualifier la
relation entre sartre et beauvoir mais
en réalité ça n'a pas beaucoup
d'importance on va pas se battre sur la
définition des mots concrètement ce que
ça veut dire c'est qu'ils étaient en
couple mais qu'il se donnait le droit
d'aller voir ailleurs
et par aller voir ailleurs il faut
entendre non seulement avoir des
relations sexuelles avec d'autres
partenaires mais aussi
avoir des relations amoureuses avec
d'autres partenaires
le modèle conjugale de sartre et
beauvoir c'était celui de la liberté
sexuelle et sentimentale
la seule condition qu'ils obligeaient à
respecter dans ce pacte de liberté
amoureuse c'était de se dire toute la
vérité
ne rien s'interdire
mais ne rien se cacher
et sartre avait une manière assez disons
sophistiqué de définir sa relation avec
simone de beauvoir il disait
notre amour est nécessaire tandis que
nos autres amours sont contingentes
amour nécessaire amours contingentes ça
fait référence à l'opposition qu'on
trouve en philosophie entre ce qui doit
être le nécessaire
et ce qui peut être
le contingent
moore nécessaire amours contingentes
autrement dit amour principal et amour
secondaire
amour est essentielle et amour
récréative
l'amour entre sartre et beauvoir était
nécessaire autrement dit il se voulait
au dessus des questions d'ordre physique
ou sexuelle
il était au delà du corps et des
conventions
on dit que les amours contingentes
c'était les amours de loisirs
c'étaient les amours
du bon temps
et donc ce mode de fonctionnement
conjugales c'était pour sartre et
beauvoir une manière de vivre leurs
aventures amoureuses mais sans les
contraintes
sans les obligations et les interdits
sociaux
des interdits sociaux qui selon la
pensée existentialiste restreignent
notre liberté en nous enfermant dans des
rôles
le papier c'est génial
la liberté et la sincérité
que dans les faits m c'est un petit peu
plus compliqué
cliquez parce qu on sait qu entre sartre
et beauvoir c'est surtout sartre qui a
profité de ce schéma conjugales
sartre était particulièrement friand de
jeunes étudiantes
il avait ce besoin de plaire aux femmes
un besoin que son physique ingrat ne lui
permettait pas forcément de combler
ce n'est pas méchant c'est factuel
et donc il sollicitait régulièrement
simone de beauvoir pour qu'elle lui
présente certaines de ses élèves afin de
coucher avec elle
parmi lesquels la bien nommée bianca
alors âgé de 16 ans qui a d'ailleurs
écrit un livre les mémoires d'une jeune
fille dérangée dans lequel elle revient
sur son triangle amoureux avec sartre et
beauvoir
donc le couple partageait ses ébats avec
deux jeunes étudiantes pour le plus
grand plaisir de sartre qui trouvaient
là l'occasion parfaite d'incarner son
rejet philosophique de l'ordre bourgeois
mais sauf qu'au bout d'un moment simone
de beauvoir a commencé à être gênés par
cette situation
par cette relation libre dans laquelle
ne s'épanouissait pas particulièrement
si bien que lorsqu'elle fit savoir à
sartre qu'elle désirait passer à une
relation exclusive
sartre lui répondit vous êtes donc une
bourgeoise
dans l'idée que l'amour exclusif c'est
le corbillard de l'amour
gardez du tandem sartre beauvoir l'image
d'un couple soudé par la liberté
d'un couple anticonformiste unis par la
loyauté et la transparence
mais la réalité était beaucoup moins
idyllique
pacte de vérité passé entre sartre et
beauvoir n'a pas tenu les mensonges sur
leurs amours contingentes ont commencé à
s'accumuler
[Musique]
jalousie s'est invitée à la table
donc c'est que sartre et beauvoir se
sont finalement retrouvés en situation
d'infidélité
infidélité au sens moral
alors même que leurs contrats d berthe
amoureuse était justement supposer les
en prémunir
il ressort de cette relation entre jean
paul sartre et simone de beauvoir un
goût d'amertume un goût d'idéal
contrarier le couple ayant finalement
échouer à incarner dans leur vie leurs
aspirations philosophique commune à la
liberté
alors après cette brève présentation de
la vie amoureuse de sartre
j'ai bien conscience que beaucoup
d'entre vous ont déjà une opinion bien
tranchée sur ce qu'ils doivent penser de
sa conception philosophique de l'amour
qu'est-ce que sartre pourrait bien
l'avoir à dire de pertinent sur l'amour
si sa propre vie amoureux su disons le
franchement un échec
eh bien mon défi ça va être de vous
montrer que la conception sartrienne de
l'amour est en fait beaucoup plus
profonde est beaucoup plus subtil qu'on
pourrait le penser à première vue
car en réalité la question n'est pas de
savoir est ce que la vie amoureuse de
sartre doit nous servir de modèle
la question est de savoir qu'est ce qui
a poussé sartre à rejeter le schéma
amoureux traditionnels pour tenter de
vivre une autre forme d'amour
pour le dire autrement qu'est ce qui
dans l'expérience ordinaire de l'amour
dans l'amour tel que nous le vivons tous
va à l'encontre de l'idéal philosophique
sartrien à savoir l'idéal de la liberté
et bien la réponse
sartre tient en une phrase
une phrase que nous allons analyser en
profondeur
qui dit
l'amour c'est le désir de s'approprier
l'autre comme être libre
est l'amour c'est le désir de
s'approprier l'autre
comme être libre
alors penchons nous sur cette phrase
essayons de comprendre ce qu'elle veut
dire
on va commencer par la première partie
de l'énoncé et mais c'est le désir de
s'approprier l'autre
qu'est ce que ça veut dire s'approprier
l'autre
s'approprier l'autre ça veut d'abord
dire
s'unir à lui
ça veut d'abord dire ne faire qu'un avec
les traîner
faire qu'un physiquement
fait l'union amoureuse c'est d'abord
l'union physique de l'acte sexuel
l'union des corps
l'acte sexuel s la pénétration d'un
corps dans un autre
c'est l'accueil d'un corps dans un autre
de ce point de vue là il s'agit bien
d'une union ou en tout cas d'une
tentative d'union
lacan disait il n'ya pas de rapport
sexuel sous-entendu les corps
s'imbriquent mais ne fusionne jamais
mais ça n'en reste pas moins le projet
être en l'autre
recevoir l'autre en soi
c'est bien ça qui se passe dans l'acte
sexuel
un projet d'union charnel
et posséder l'autre
allégorique de décrire ce qui se produit
dans l'acte sexuel
en dehors de l'acte sexuel le besoin de
proximité tactile avec l'attrait mais
traduit aussi ce désir d'union
le besoin de s'embrasser
le besoin de se serrer dans les bras
se sentir l'un l'autre
c'est bien là encore un désir d'union
qui est à l'oeuvre
maintenant si on sort de la sphère
physique et qu'on parle de la sphère
sociale
dans le couple comme entité sociale on
observe aussi cette tendance à l'union
cette tendance à se comporter non plus
en tant qu'individu mais en tant que
membre du couple
au point que le couple finit par devenir
une personne à part entière
savez quand vous invitez un ami à une
soirée et qui vous répond on a quelque
chose de prévu
on a quelque chose de prévu
alors même que la deuxième personne du
couple n'a pas été mentionné dans la
conversation
et alors qu'on est en couple on ne
pensait on n'agit plus totalement en
tant qu'individu
on pense on agit au nom du couple
tout ce que ça peut occasionner de
diminution de la personnalité
le couple amoureux c'est l'entité issue
de deux individualités qui substitue aux
deux personnalités individuelles une
personnalité collective
et c'est en ce sens là qu'il est
possible de définir l'amour comme désir
d'appropriation de l'autre
entendu au sens de désir d'absorption de
l'autre
au sens
d'assimilation physique et symbolique de
l'autre dans une entité nouvelle qui est
le couple
mais alors du coup la question qui se
pose c'est comment passe-t-on d'un désir
d'union à un désir de possession
parce que c'est pas exactement la même
chose
voir s'unir à l'autre sans pour autant
vouloir le posséder
bien en réalité non on peut pas
ne pas vous s'unir à l'autre sans
vouloir le posséder
pourquoi mais la réponse est très simple
parce que nous restons des individus
des individus avec des sensibles
différentes
désirs différents
avec des perceptions du monde différente
donc si l'amour et désir d'union mais
que dans les faits nous restons des
individus l'amour est confronté à un
problème
le problème des sentiments de l'autre
parce qu'aimer ce n'est pas seulement
éprouver des sentiments pour l'autre
c'est en même temps désiré que l'autre
éprouvent les mêmes sentiments pour nous
écrit
mais
c'est essentiellement le projet des
traînées
retenons bien ça aimer c'est le projet
d'être aimé
c'est ça l'amour
vouloir être mais
si la personne vous aimez ne vous aime
pas en retour vous allez en être
affectée
souffrir
quand on est quand on cherche à lui
plaire
on cherche à se rendre désirable à ses
yeux
ce
son
et donc si l'amour n'était pas désir
lettre mm la séduction n'existerait pas
si cyrano refuse de dire à roxane qu'il
est l'auteur des lettres de christian ce
n'est pas parce qu'il ne veut pas la
séduire
il en brûle d'envié
peur qu en lui faisant cette révélation
elle le rejette
a peur de perdre le peu d'amour qu'elle
lui témoigne à savoir son respect et son
affection
et c'est parce que roxanne lui dira
finalement qu'elle aime qu'il acceptera
de mourir le coeur léger
et même ses désirs et être aimé
autrement dit
l'amour exige
si profiter
et c'est à partir du moment où cette
réciprocité amoureuse est obtenu
que va commencer à s'enclencher ce que
sartre décrit comme étant un processus
d'asservissement de lettres est né
processus d'asservissement de l'être
aimé autrement dit le fait que l'amant
va nourrir à l'égard de l'être aimé un
certain nombre d'attentes
à dire
certain nombre d'exigences
alors de quelle date on parle au thon
par exemple peut l'être aimé nous montre
son amour
qu'ils l'expriment
et s'ils ne l'expriment pas s'il préfère
passer ses soirées à jouer sur
l'ordinateur plutôt qu'à passer du temps
avec moi
je vais en être mécontents
je vais éventuellement le lui reprocher
parce que j'attends de l'être aimé qui
même en retour
et comment puis-je être sûr qu il même
s'il n'en fait pas la démonstration par
son comportement
vous connaissez la citation il n'y a pas
d'amour il n'ya que des preuves d'amour
sous-entendu l'amour c'est quelque chose
qui doit se traduire dans le
comportement
et peu importe si le fait de lui
demander des preuves de son amour ne
changera rien à la réalité de son amour
l'important étant que l'autre joue le
jeu de la relation amoureuse
c'est pour ça qu'on attend de l'autre
des preuves de son amour
on attend des preuves d'amour on les
obtient pas
et au lieu de se demander si cette
absence de preuves ne serait pas
justement une preuve de l'absence
à preuve de l'absence d'amour de l'autre
on demande des preuves
voir se persuader que l'autre nous aime
comme nous l'aimons
l'important n'est pas la réalité du
sentiment
l'entente et la réalité de l'apparence
du sentiment
et l'autre n'est plus la personne que
j'aime l'autre devient celui qui a le
devoir de mai mais autant que je laime
c'est ça le désir de possession
le désir de confort mais l'autre
le désir de modeler son comportement à
nos attentes de confirmation
aimer c'est à temps de l'autre la
confirmation de son amour pour nous et
donc la confirmation du bien fondé de
notre amour
je t'aime à quelqu'un
ce n'est pas pour qu'il vous répondre
merci
autre attente profonde
de moi aussi
parce que ce moi aussi cristallise la
promesse de l'union
la preuve d'une réciprocité
dire je t'aime c'est dire
que tu m'aimes
par quoi sont motivés la plupart spitz
amoureuse
par le sentiment que l'autre ne fait pas
ce qu'il devrait faire pour maintenir
l'union amoureuse
par le sentiment que l'autre ne fait pas
assez d'efforts
remarquez les mots qu'on utilise
faire des efforts
montrer à l'autre qu'on aime ça devient
c'est fou quand on y pense
faire des efforts
et ça montre bien l'idée que cherche à
exprimer sartre à savoir que l'amour
prend régulièrement la forme d'une lutte
pour la reconnaissance
là
couple est rarement une sinécure
âge
un couple
tu es à 2
des problèmes qu'on aurait jamais eu
seul
c'est tout au nom de l'amour qu'on a des
attentes envers l'autre
alain connu quelqu'un qu'on croise dans
la rue
on n'a pas d'attentes envers lui
sa personne nous indiffère
ces sentiments nous indiffère
donc à moins d'être quelqu'un de très
empathique et de se projeter dans sa
situation les choix et paroles et les
actions de l'inconnu on s'en contrefout
on sent qu'on fou parce qu'on n'est pas
sentimentalement engagé avec lui
donc il peut bien faire ce qu'il veut
contre votre bien aimé la personne qui
habite votre coeur et vos pensées
elle ne peut pas faire ce qu'elle veut
soit vous engage
parce qu'il vous secte
le désir de posséder l'autre le désir de
s'approprier l'autre
c'est la traduction on de notre désir
d'union avec l'autre accompagnée de la
conscience que l'autre nous est
fondamentalement inaccessible
l'autre est condamné à rester l'autre
s'il a conscience de l'autre nous est
accessible
si nous étions capables de nous
téléporté dans le coeur de l'autre
nous n'éprouvons rions pas ce besoin de
savoir ce qu'il ressent pour nous
et c'est parce qu'il nous est impossible
d'être absolument certain que l'autre
nous aime autant que nous l'aimons que
nous allons vouloir effectuer le
contrôle qualité de ses sentiments
autrement dit vérifier par tous les
moyens possibles que l'être aimé et
digne de notre amour
et c'est là que l'amant se transforme en
inspecteur des sentiments
en contrôleur des sentiments
parce que notre désir profond lorsque
nous aimons quelqu'un
être son absolue
c'est d'être l'objet exclusif de son
amour
et donc si je vois l'être aimé perdu
dans ses pensées
dû poser la fameuse question
pense
parce que j'ai besoin de savoir à quoi
ils pensent
j'ai besoin avoir un droit de regard sur
ses pensées
j'ai besoin de savoir que j'occupe ses
pensées
parce que si je n'occupe pas ses pensées
ça veut dire qu'ils ne m'aiment pas
autant que je laime
et ça cible
donc je vais lui en vouloir
je vais lui en vouloir parce qu'il ne
pense pas à moi
ouah parce qu'il ne m'envoie pas assez
de messages
ce qui ne me témoigne pas suffisamment
d'affection
en attente de réciprocité
forme en colonisateur de la conscience
de l'autre
alors ici je voudrais prendre le temps
de faire une petite parenthèse
souvent dire que ce ne serait pas ça le
vrai amour
que le vrai amour
ce serait l'amour désintéressé
moore
sans rien en retour
alors que là depuis tout à l'heure on
parle d'attentes on parle d'exigence
parle même de lutte pour la
reconnaissance
tout ça ressemble moins à de l'amour
ado lego
très bien
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire en le
vrai amour
qu'est ce que le vrai amour
sinon l'amour que nous recherchons tous
l'amour dont nous faisons l'expérience
et que nous désirons vivre
or l'amour que nous en vivre
ce n'est pas un amour à sens unique
moore bénévoles
l'amour
bon c'est un amour partagé
c'est un amour qui peut voir son reflet
dans le regard de l'autre
l'amour
c'est quand l'autre répond à votre
caresse par un sourire
autrement dit l'amour
moore qui se manifeste par le désir de
l'autre
par le désir de la présence de l'autre
et qui fait que lorsque la personne que
vous aimez sera absente
elle va vous manquer
ça physique va vous manquer
vous allez penser à elle
elle pour compenser son absence physique
par sa présence mentale
c'est ça l'amour dans sa forme
réellement vécu
si demain
vous aimez vous annonce qu'elle part
vivre en australie
et que tout va bien se passer parce que
votre amour est au delà de la présence
physique vous allez faire une drôle de
tête
parce que pour vous cet amour là il
n'est pas satisfaisant
et c'est normal
parce que nous ne sommes pas encore des
dieux
nous sommes deux mortels
donc l'amour dont nous faisons
l'expérience
c'est un amour qui réclament la présence
de l'autre
l amour qui ne se
fais pas de la connexion spirituelle
avec l'être aimé
mais qui a besoin d'en avoir la
confirmation charnel
on sait que les grecs de l'antiquité
avait huit mots différents pour dire à
moore
qui distinguait l'amour passion de
l'amour amitié ou de l'amour charité
mais dans les faits contre on parle
d'amour on parle de l'amour passion
on parle d'eux amour qui pousse deux
êtres à l'union charnelle
l'amour de juni et britannicus
l'amour de camille et perdit conte
de roméo et juliette
donc pour revenir
m l'amour n'est pas seulement un
sentiment
c'est un sentiment qui charrie avec lui
des attentes
charrier avec lui des exigences à
l'égard de l'être aimé et c'est en ce
sens que l'amour est bel et bien désir
de possession
parce qu'en plat quand nos attentes sur
l'être aimé
nous les obligeons à une certaine
manière d'être
nous les obligeons à jouer son rôle d' à
traîner
n'obligeons avec
tim ans pour nous
à être affectueux à être attentionné
et là vous allez me dire encore heureux
c'est normal
oui mais la question n'est pas de savoir
c'est normal ou pas
la question est de savoir qu'est ce que
ça révèle
qu'est-ce que ça traduit de la nature du
sentiment amoureux
ce que ça traduit c'est qu'à travers tim
en amoureux
maman cherche à s'approprier la liberté
de l'être aimé
l'amant cherche à avoir la mainmise non
seulement sur son corps
mais sur son esprit et ses sentiments
et oui c'est normal
mais ce n'est pas parce que c'est normal
de désir et s'approprier la très mé que
ça veut dire que je ne cherche pas à me
l'approprier
oui je cherche approprié
oui je cherche à le conformer à mes
attentes
parce que je veux que son sud témoigne
du sentiment que je veux qu'il éprouve
envers moi
faisant que la servie à mes exigences
pour reprendre formulation des stoïciens
on pourrait dire qu mêmes ce n'est pas
vouloir que l'autre soit ce qu'il est
c'est vouloir que l'autre
soit ce qu'on désire qu'il soit
et le jour où l'autre n'agit pas comme
j'attends de lui qu'il agisse le jour où
l'autre contrarie mes exigences
je me sens trahi
je me sens trompé
sans vous que ce sont mes attentes qui
sont responsables de ma déception
sans voir que ma souffre ce n'est que la
conséquence du désir que j'ai eus
d'asservir l'autre à ma volonté
aimer l'autre c'est laid mais dans la
mesure où son comportement
répond à nos attentes
on disait oh si que vous aimez se
comportent d'une manière qui vous
déplaît le sentiment de réprobation que
vous allez éprouver envers elle va
prendre une forme beaucoup plus intense
que si c'était un inconnu qui avait agi
ainsi
le fait est que plus on aime quelqu'un
plus on place sur lui des attentes
élevées
on n'est jamais par quelqu'un dont on
n'entend rien
ça que c'est l'amour le plus fort
généralement les rancoeurs les plus
fortes
parce que la déception est d'autant plus
grande que les attentes étaient hautes
les crimes sionnel illustre cette
porosité entre l'amour et la haine
moore déçu
que
suis honoré
en faisant ce qu'il n'aurait pas dû
faire
ou en ne faisant pas
ce qu'il aurait dû faire
dans tous les cas s'il y a des son
amoureuse
toujours l'autre qui sera perçu comme
responsable
c'est toujours l'autre qui n'aura pas su
faire ce qu'il fallait faire
deux conduits là nous sommes tous et mal
aimé
l'idée que l'amour est essentiellement
désir de possession de la très mé n'est
pas très difficile à comprendre
la nuance est
peuls à relativiser
c'est quelque chose dont on a tous déjà
fait l'expérience
mais notre analyse de la conception
sartrienne de l'amour serait incomplète
elle serait même totalement erronée
si on omettait de rappeler la deuxième
partie de sa citation
je vous rappelle la citation
aimer c'est le désir de s'approprier
l'autre co m libre
pour sartre l'amour n'est donc pas
seulement désir de possession de l'autre
il est désir de possession de l'autre en
tant qu'être libre
et là il alors expliquer ce que sartre
entend par là
sartre nous dîmes et mais c'est vouloir
et rennais
c'est ça le sol de l'amour
vouloir être aimé
quand vous aimez quelqu'un de toutes vos
forces le fait de savoir que cette
personne vous aime en retour
produire en vous un sentiment
indescriptible
un sentiment d'unité
un sentiment de plénitude
tim ans d'avoir trouvé votre partie
manquante
mais qu'est-ce qui fait vous allez
prouver un tel sentiment
bien on nous dit
c'est le fait que vous n'ayez aucune
idée de pourquoi l'autre vous m
c'est le fait que d'une certaine manière
responsable de l'amour de l'autre pour
vous
quand deux guerres m elles sont unies
par une double ignorance
ignorance des causes de leur amour pour
l'autre mais aussi
l'ignorance des causes de l'amour de
l'autre pour elle
c'est ça
du sentiment amoureux
son quart r 2 go incidence
coïncidence littérale de ce qui coïncide
et les spinoziste pourront bien invoquer
les lois de la causalité
le phénomène qui se produit et si
singulièrement intense que pour les
individus qu'ils éprouvent il prend des
allures de magie
ce qui rend l'amour de l'autre digne de
valeur
qu'il aurait pu ne jamais être
on peut tomber amoureux qu'elle un sens
que ce soit réciproque
quelqu'un peut tomber amoureux de nous
sans que ce soit réciproque
et c'est même ce qui se produit dans
l'immense majorité des cas
vraiment rare d'avoir des sentiments
intenses pour quelqu'un et que cette
intensité se retrouvent dans les
sentiments de l'autre à notre égard
c'est extrêmement rare
bien justement nous dit sartre
c'est ça le fondement de la valeur que
nous accordons à l'amour de l'autre
heures imprévisible
sankara ren
immaîtrisable
parce que si on pouvait contrôler les
sentiments de l'autre
si on pouvait décider que l'autre nous m
son amour n'aurait plus aucune valeur
parce qu'ils ne viendraient plus de lui
mais de nous
il est certain s'il existait une formule
magique pour rendre l'autre amoureux de
nous
amour s'en trouverait fortement dévalué
ce que les marabouts n'ont pas compris
c'est que l'amour qui proviendraient
d'un sort d'un charme ou d'un filtre
est un amour qui en réalité n'intéresse
personne
amour factice
parce que
ce n'est pas de l'amour
l'amour doit venir d'un être libres de
nous aimer ou de ne pas nous aimer
libre non pas au sens de choix
au sens de spontané
au sens
d'impulsion intérieur
l'amour que vous pourriez téléguidé
que vaudra l'amour que vous pourriez
contrôlé avec un curseur
il dre instantanément toute sa valeur
anton amoureux d'une machine
amoureux d'un automate
amoureux de quelqu'un dont on
fondamentalement pas programmer les
sentiments
10 l'amour de l'autre n'a de valeur que
parce que l'autre pourrait ne pas
m'aimer
l'amour de l'autre n'a de valeur
que basque il est libre
en d'autres on est là est tout le
paradoxe
c'est que
que nous aimons dans l'autre
c'est le pouvoir qui l'a
de ne pas nous aimer
on a dit tout à l'heure que l'amour nous
poussait à désirer l'amour de l'autre
et ce désir de l'amour de l'autre peut
nous pousser à vouloir en prendre le
contrôle
parce qu'un amour non réciproque
signerait l'échec de notre amour
or ce que montre sartre c'est qu'en
réalité
si nous pouvions effectivement prendre
le contrôle des sentiments de l'autre
nous en saurions insatisfaits
nous ne voulons pas que l'autre nous
aime parce que l' oblige aurions à nous
mêmes
voulons que l'autre nous m
parce qu'il n'a aucune raison
particulière de nous mêmes
non pas que l'autre nous aiment pas
reprogrammation
ni par obligation
parce que dans les deux cas
on n'est plus une passion libre
un mécanique
sartre prend l'exemple du mât âge
comme engagement moral à aimer l'autre
il explique qu'un amour issu d'un
engagement moral perd sa qualité et sa
valeur
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on se marie
on prête serment
promettez vous de les mener jusqu'à ce
que la mort vous sépare
oui
mais enfin qu'est ce que ça veut dire
que voit
qui ne tient que parce qu'on l'a promis
alors oui il ya quelque chose de très
noble dans le serment de fidélité
pour l'autre et si fort qu'il éclipse
tous les amours potentiel et prend des
allures d'absolu
très bien
et pourquoi m quelque chose qui ne
dépend pas de nous
un sentiment ne se contrôle pas
un sentiment se décrète pas
on peut promettre de rester fidèle
fidèle aux infidèles ça oui on le décide
et promettre de rester amoureux
totalement différent
l'engagement c'est tout l'inversé
l'amour
pourquoi parce que l'amour ne relève pas
de la morale
parce que l'amour
demandez à l'autre vous aimez
parce qu'un jour il en a fait la
promesse dans une mairie
ça marche pas
et même si ça marchait que vaudrait cet
amour
que vaut un amour qui ne repose que sur
le respect d'un contrat
que voit moore qui besoin d'une
signature pour être rappelé à l'ordre
on n'aime pas quelqu'un parce qu'on a
signé un contrat
cain malgré les contrats
on aime quelqu'un malgré la raison
malgré la morale malgré les obligations
et le serment de fidélité n'a pas pour
fonction de signifier l'amour
chon de signifier
l'institutionnalisation de cet amour
le mariage c'est dire au monde
voici notre équipe
mais l'amour n'a pas
je pourrais être l'amour
il n'a pas besoin de contrat
l'amour c'est la libre qui choisit sa
voie
pour sartre la condition ce défi la
liberté
contrairement aux choses
n'est pas déterminé dans ses actions
il a le pouvoir de faire
dit de faire
à chaque seconde vous êtes en capacité
de choisir d'agir d'une manière plutôt
que d'une autre
parce que vous possédez une conscience
que cette conscience vous permet de vous
projeter dans des possibilités et que
c'est vous qui allez opter pour l'une ou
l'autre de ses possibilités
importe notre détermination
porte que notre prochaine action ne soit
que la conséquence d'un enchaînement de
causes et d'effets
fede que personne d'autre que vous sera
l'auteur de votre prochaine action
l'existentialisme de sartre c'est l'idée
que l'être humain
une liberté en action
et qu aimer une personne
c'est m mais une liberté qui se portent
librement sur nous
l'autre c'est tall man se qui échappe à
ma maîtrise
c'est celui qui n'a pas besoin de moi
pour accomplir son projet existentielle
je pourrais disposer
il serait intégralement soumis à ma
volonté
quelqu'un qui perdrait aussitôt à mes
yeux sa qualité de personne
d'être libre
liberté m c'est ça qui nous plaît chez
l'autre
son quart
repris à bhl
quand nous aimons quelqu'un nous aimons
tu es
nous
appel
ce
une ac arles de l'infini
al'inverse
quelqu'un qui et intégralement a servi
ou quelqu'un qu'on forcerait à nous
aimer
quelqu'un dont l'amour n'aurait plus
aucun attrait
parce qu'il perdrait son caractère libre
c'est à dire indépendant de notre
volonté
nous aimons l'autre à proportion de son
pouvoir
de ne pas nous mêmes
et c'est là qu'on peut comprendre le
grand paradoxe de l'amour selon sartre
qu'est que l'amour est à la fois désir
d'asservissement
hergé de l'asservissement
l'amour et désir de posséder l'autre
en même temps qu'ils les désirs
d'indépendance de l'autre
vous aimez
forme à vos attentes
this face vos moindres désirs
comme si son équilibre en dépendait
amour pour elle s'évanouit
dès lors que l'autre lacarne plus la
transcendance
dès lors que l'autre n'incarne plus la
liberté en mouvement qui a fait naître
votre amour
vous n'aimez plus
parce qu'alors avait plus en face de
vous une personne
vous n'avez plus en face de vous une
transcendance
mais un être asservi
être mais cesse d'être un absolu
il devient votre ce
canton amoureux d'une chose
une fois qu'on a compris ça une fois
qu'on a prix que l'amour était à la fois
désir l'asservissement et désirs
d'indépendance
as compris du même coup que
st
drame de l'amour
ça compte shu
quand là de l'autre et à qui notre amour
s'en va
à la rochelle d'une nouvelle
ce à rires
je cite
celui qui veut être aimé ne désire pas
l'asservissement de l'être aimé il ne
tient pas à devenir l'objet d'une
passion débordante et mécanique il ne
veut pas posséder un automatisme si
tristan et iseult sont affolés par un
filtre il intéresse moins
et il arrive que l'asservissement total
de l'être aimé tue l'amour de l'amant le
but est dépassée amants se retrouvent
seuls s'il aimait s'est transformé en
automate incidemment ne désire t-il pas
posséder les mais comme on possède une
chose ils réclament un type spécial
d'appropriation il veut posséder une
liberté comme liberté
mais d'autre part il ne saurait se
satisfaire de cette forme éminente de la
liberté qu'est l'engagement libre et
volontaire qui se contenterait d'un
amour qui se donnerait comme pure
fidélité à la fois juré qui donc
accepterait de s'entendre dire je vous
aime parce que je me suis librement
engagé à vous aimer et que je ne veux
pas me dédire je vous aime par fidélité
à moi même ainsi l'amendement le serment
et s'irrite du serment il veut être aimé
par une liberté et réclame que cette
liberté comme liberté ne soit plus libre
il veut à la fois que la liberté de
l'autre se déterminent elle même à
devenir amour est à la fois que cette
liberté soit captivé par elle-même
qu'elle se retourne sur elle même comme
dans la folie comme dans le rêve pour
vouloir sa captivité et cette captivité
doit être des missions libre et enchaîné
à la fois entre nos mains ce n'est pas
le déterminisme passionnel que nous
désirons chez autrui dans l'amour ni
liberté hors d'atteinte mais c'est une
liberté qui joue le déterminisme
passionnel et se prend à son jeu
chez l'autre
en même temps ce on veut le déposséder
liberté
ce congé
l'autre est en même temps
ce qui nous en détourne
son
ce moment
l'être humain est un paradoxe
et semble e
tout ce que nous si on faire pour nous
affranchir de ce paradoxe
c'est
prendre
ce que
on est la marque de notre condition
prendre conscience que la deux de notre
accomplissement
c'est nous mêmes
l'autre n'est pas responsable
des attentes que nous fixe sur lui
il n'est pas responsable
victoire
d'admirer
de posséder
puis de nous détourner de lui
ce que nous y sommes parvenus
prendre
caractère contradictoire de l'amour
prendre conscience du chemin
reste à parcourir
pour nous accorder avec nous mêmes
et que s'il y a ça aimer l'autre
allez même malgré nos attentes
tel qu'il est
c'est parce que l'autre n'est
or ni hier
moi
c'est parce que l'autre
est comme moi
est un autre moi
je vous remercie
[Musique]